hey I was in Toronto when
you bought when you brought
the cup to uh Westwood how old are you I don't
know they're ready to go in Columbus stars of
both squads fans of all players the young fan
Tilly this is a young 19-year-old rookie guys
like rinsky Boon Jenner all those guys have
been awesome coming in and show me the ropes
a little bit and help me be comfortable really
quickly I those guys a lot so it's great
you got a mix of you know some older guys
who are you know playing really well and have
been around and have that experience and then
also some younger guys who try to learn and you
know make their Mark in the [Applause] league
with the first 10 minutes 5 6 7 10 minutes
we set the temple and we play a simple and
fast game all right and no doubt who's the hunger
harder team here tonight that's us let's go come
on [Music]
suits I've been a little too crazy in the
in the diesel I'm going to be like a little
bit more calm tonight I W I won't be
running around as much all right I'm
going to blow it and then I'm going to tell
you when okay back up for me fell here we go
ja rosic in front control over to Jenner
score rosic to control to Jenner dude that
was a sick look though you faked him and you
dropped them really fast yeah we going to try
with me on the wall me on the [Applause] wall
oh yeah okay Wings slash cuz their D's
pinching I'll stay underneath tell him
tell tell him Wing or slash I'll I'll stay
under so you can go go go you go yeah here
comes fan Tilly plays it to himself he'll race
and get it he's got marenko going to the net
marenko how do I say you're do to score you're
do I got to learn r I like my
line I want to learn Russian on
the softly down the wall where it's intercepted
then Sean steps up a chance to clear
the jackets didn't do Shane Marchman
score it work Dutch out of [Applause] point
so Dallas now outscored in the first period
13 to6 this year but the second period has
been their period outscoring their opponents
14-6 two on one box up and Smith save rebound
[Applause] SC Place hey Johnny remember that
one I got it kind of one time to two you think
I could have taken a step to make like a one-time
option or was like that guy too high I thought he
was like right on top of me I just wanted
to hand it off I don't know soft chip soft
chip duchaine for the lead save by Martin
and it goes in the net on the rebound I
think that's what we got to do though like
when you got that in the corner and just Rim
out like move it before they can cuz it's still
like a swarm hey hey so after 40 minutes down
two nothing the Dallas Stars have clawed
their way back and they lead by [Music]
one get the head R shot score tip in
front Tyler s and the Stars lead four
to two dropped two games in a row and um
got down too early in this one and I think
that just kind of shows the resilience that we
have here and yeah never had a game we great
with bouncing back they could tell that you
know will try to take with us throughout the
[Music]
season